[Musique]
en cet été 1793 il n'avait pas encore 16
ans il était garde au puy du fou
il s'appelait jacques mobilier les 500
participants du spectacle ce soir là
vendée entendent bien le 16 juin
prochain prouver que la qualité n'est
pas que parisienne jean piat françois
chaumette marie dubois entend contrer
les textes et alexandre lagoya composer
un thème
voilà pour paris le reste la vendée s'en
charge et le reste trouvera que le
bénévolat n'est pas mort comme on le dit
trop souvent 500 participants 250
figurants plus de vingt cavaliers des
artificiers et cetera et cetera tous de
la région et chacune des 13 communes
participantes on verra une trentaine
d'acteurs il revenait à la maison
changer de chemise
son visage s'assombrit ce soir la vendée
est un spectacle que le conseil général
a rendu possible en rachetant au mois
d'octobre le château du puy du fou
il s'agissait pour lui pour les
habitants de la région de restaurer ce
château renaissance un des seuls en
france à être construits en granit et
installés par la suite un musée régional
rejeté revers du fossé comme des fleurs
faucher qu'il y ait ici un site
remarquable
il y à une scène naturelle est
extraordinaire il y a à la fois le
château la terrasse les temps les temps
de 5 hectares une prairie un promontoire
dans cette prairie où nous pourrons
placer les gens vraiment une semaine
extraordinaire à ce scénario évoque
l'histoire de la vendée à travers le
témoignage que peut nous apporter le
château du puy du fou qui a vécu
lui-même tous les grands événements
heureux et malheureux de l'histoire des
bocages et plus généralement de
l'histoire de la vendée
un jour il s'est mis à pleurer il
enrageait courant là bas dans la prairie
éclaboussé de sang est debout face au
château en flammes
sa lèvre inférieure trembler sur ses
dents serrées lui non plus n'avait rien
pu faire
les colonnes infernales de turreau était
passé pour ce soir là vendée on attend
déjà 25000 spectateurs première le 16
juin 1978
[Musique]